don't bring anyone love into this I like
the I like an honest exchange yeah you
know like I we talked about this on the
live show a little bit Hugh Hefner's
death I don't I don't think he was some
great fucking pioneer I think he was
kind of a creeper and he had a mansion
full of broken broken girls who you know
he lived there for free
but he didn't pay them he had like a
weekly stipend and then it was a coup
come watch your movie yeah like pajamas
and then he but fucked a lot of them but
sex them because he didn't want anyone
prank that's true read read Holly Holly
Madison's book about the butt fucking
yes disgusting such a power move like I
know some people certainly is certainly
some I know women that are you know very
much into it for the physical sense a
like that that's for them is euphoria
right and there's obviously people who
that's their sexual turn-on but in and
of itself like if you strip let's say
someone's preferences to that away
that's an aggressive move yeah it's a
it's a dominant movie fuck you in your
ass bottle yeah your butthole is very
sensitive and and oh my god you guys are
so disgusting
yeah that's poop I guess they had
credited that pervert he's like oh the
big sexual revolution yeah but it is
still according to like a white guy's
preference not fucking though and only
blondes oh it was like it was one type
of woman that he liked it was like you
know the cookie cutter big tits Pam
Anderson Joe if you had little hungry
tits forget it you had a big ass forget
it was like his way and I I liked Larry
Flynt way better yeah we talked about
this my peddling Larry Flynt yeah just
because it's honest
he was like put that fucking candle
holder in your place right yeah you want
a hundred dollars yeah
just read it it's great if you put your
hand further up there yeah and there's
no horse shit mystique of the mansion
and living with Hefner and he was a real
it was just like like I'm a pig and it's
an even exchange here's some cash spread
your beef and there was no convoluted
thing of like how many girlfriends does
a guy have I'm a busta my gold
wheelchair real quick yeah well and he
said to like that well Holly said in her
book that they he would be like alright
you two make out and then they'd make
out he'd you know jerk it that's cool
and then they'd thrill like the new girl
at him so that they were off the hook
for the night all right
deal with him like hop out that you got
half tonight is that I was cool fuck him
about that exciting and I your
great-great grandpa yeah and I can die
and last night with the live show and
people were like yeah it's great
exposure okay well you think about it
yeah let's think about the stars that
really came out of Playboy you had your
Pamela Anderson that's the anomaly I
think she she was Pamela Anderson is a
genuine like an icon she's Canadian but
but became an American yeah sure maybe
Jenny McCarthy she was famous before she
did it she was you know I remember other
than that I mean who's who was really
static Carmen Electra playmate yeah yep
but she was also fuckin Prince and ya
know she's a chicken egg we were you a
hoe before you know I don't know I don't
know i don't i don't i just i just you
know it's funny to holly was saying that
the mansion was all rundown and shit too
she's like it's not nice there's oldest
alright but you know they put in bunk
beds in the playmates room i don't know
what why you would give up on keeping it
like super night because it's expensive
i'm sure you've got the money now retile
the grotto they're like hey do you want
new carpets and everybody's like how am
i though it's three thousand dollars
that's a lot of money
yeah leave the old carpet there okay if
i don't think i don't think there's
playboy selling anymore somebody in the
bottle
okay we'll get the new girl down here
immediately but don't you imagine that
once the internet started that who the
heck is even looking at playboy of
course when you can change everything
yeah like no one's buying that shit for
the last 20 years you used to get I mean
when I was a kid
obviously there's no internet and the
magazine was just tits that's the one
thing that's kind of nice right cuz you
were excited by that you're excited by
seeing some bush right look oh and just
like a beautiful body yeah man that's
I'm gonna jerk off to this right right
and then the internet ruin desensitized
you completely yeah really a naked body
so yeah what can it do can I can we stab
it can we put it in a toilet bowl why
didn't she cry and more yeah is she
gagging choking I put my fist down hard
on with that
isn't that funny yeah that's so funny
it's really crazy man yeah I guess my
only beef two is like I always want to
see women exploiting other women and not
making the money yeah make the money if
you're gonna exploit the women at least
give them the fucking the money dickhead
yeah yeah make that money
come on sluts make your own stuff yeah
you know because it all boils down to
the finances dude he's got the power
they don't have the power sucks I think
these days I'm not I mean I don't know
the specifics the names the things but
there's definitely some women I think
doing some producing definitely and look
and I'm I listen there's two sides to
this debate in in the women women's
world there are girls who find being
naked very empowering and very you know
awesome and then there are other women
that just are like it's not for me so
you know I it's just not for me
personally but I understand why some
women think it's a great thing to do it
feels good that they really feel
powerful I mean you know more power to
you but sure I think that guys have a
creeper yeah yeah old as hell he's super
old how old was he when he died it was
like over 90 damn I would think it's
even grosser just to sleep next to him
these are all just old smelling and your
body's just you know just falling apart
literally decaying yeah yeah like you
know the muscle has gone in your face
and you know like he probably like and
like y'all right sounds like I breathe
oh my god
that's why his up fuck you in the
morning I gotta take my shot lucky in
the butt in the morning okay that's why
the house was so damn well you know how
old people's houses look like yeah
and they they start to smell and yeah
you're like that's broken in there like
oh so am i I'm saying like somebody else
should have been like I'm gonna run this
keep this house Christine I know I think
his daughter took over the dealings of
the the magazine and the don't waste
money on his house yeah old piece of
shit he's gonna die and then we're gonna
kick out all these sluts and then I'm
gonna take over so do you think well you
think that house is I think the house is
like the property's worth a lot the
house is probably I think yeah the house
is probably dogshit but then it's like
what's the house worth in terms of its
significance in other words you know the
historical value of it being the Playboy
Mansion all the AIDS that's been
transferred that's all the herpes and
gonorrhea that have been transmitted the
grotto can you think of anything grosser
at least I mean Larry Flynt I feel like
was just straightforward and and you
know didn't ya send the girls and you
know the girls can't say no yeah that no
one's saying no why couldn't it just be
an even extent people said no over the
years now is definitely the day you
found a strip right yeah you should out
of here which is terrible like that's a
harem then you're you're keeping women
hostage you're not it's not neat it's
not a fair exchange no you know
[Music]